the number of values of theta in the
interval from negative PI over two to PI
over two and it's not including those
because we have curly parentheses around
it such that theta does not equal n PI
over five so it's not a multiple of PI
over five for N equals zero plus or
minus 1 plus or minus two and tangent of
theta is equal to cotangent of five
theta as well as sine of two theta is
equal to cosine of 4 theta is we have to
find a number of values of theta that
satisfy all of these things so just from
the get-go it seems like we're going to
have to solve for theta and convert
between sine and cosine which is
essentially what you're doing between
tangent and cotangent we'll do that a
little bit and those of you who know me
if you're actually taking an exam under
time pressure I don't recommend you
reproving your trig identities from
first principles but for education
purposes I always like to do it so let's
just let me just draw a right triangle
right over here if you're actually going
to take the IIT je exam I recommend
having most of the trig identities at
your fingertips but let's say that's a
right triangle and let's it call let's
call that theta and then this angle
right over here is going to be PI over 2
minus theta pi over 2 minus theta if
we're in radians right 90 degrees right
here is PI over 2 the whole triangle
right over here is 180 degrees which is
PI so this is PI over 2 and so what
these two guys are going to have to add
up to the other PI over 2 so this is PI
over 2 minus theta so let's think about
what cosine of theta is cosine of theta
sohcahtoa cosine of 2 theta is this side
let's call this a B and C it's it is
going to be the adjacent side so cosine
is adjacent over me
so Chi Toa sohcahtoa cosine is adjacent
over hypotenuse so cosine of theta is B
over C adjacent over hypotenuse it's
equal to B over C but what's also equal
to B over C if we look at this angle
over here from this angles point of view
B is the opposite side so it's opposite
over hypotenuse for this angles point of
view so it's also equal to the sine the
sine of
I over 2 minus theta so we got our first
main identity here that the cosine of
theta is equal to the sine of PI over 2
minus theta and we could go the other
way around use the exact same logic to
get that the sine of theta the sine of
theta is equal to the cosine of PI over
2 minus theta so that'll be pretty
useful when we try to solve this
equation right over here and we can even
use it when we solve this one because if
I were to write down the cotangent of
five theta let me write this down so the
cotangent cotangent of not cosine the
cotangent of five theta this is the
exact same thing the cotangent of five
theta is the exact same thing as the
cosine of five theta over the sine of
five theta it's just 1 over the tangent
and this is the same thing I can convert
the cosine into sine using this identity
up here this is the sine of PI over 2 PI
over two minus five theta over the
cosine over the cosine of PI over 2
minus five theta 4 here I'm just using
this identity over here and this is the
exact same thing as the tangent as the
tangent of PI over 2 minus five theta
and since we're going to actually have
to solve this equation eventually and we
want to make sure we get all of the
solutions to this equation let's just
for one thing you might want to remember
is when you take a tangent of an angle
and I'll just draw the unit circle here
so if I have some angle let me draw my
axes and let's say that this right here
is Theta you probably remember that the
state ax is essentially the slope of the
line formed it's it's opposite over
adjacent it's the slope of the line it's
the slope of the line formed or by the
radius in the unit circle so this theta
is going to have the exact same tangent
as if we add 180 degrees or if we add PI
to this so if you add PI you get you get
theta plus pi so this whole angle right
over here is theta plus PI theta plus pi
and it's tangent is going to be the same
thing it's the slope of the radius is
going to be the same so you can add
multiples of pi to a tangent value and
you're going to get the exact same value
so let me put let me put some multiples
of PI over here so that we can make sure
that we get all of the solutions so with
that said with this written we can now
solve this first equation over here and
then we can worry about some of these
other constraints later so tangent of
theta is equal to cotangent of five
theta well so we can write tangent of
theta is equal to instead of writing
cotangent of five theta we can write is
equal to the tangent of PI over two
minus five theta plus integer multiples
of Pi and so the tangent of this is
equal to tangent of that these things
could be equal to each other so we get
theta is equal to PI over two minus five
theta plus plus n PI or at minimum this
could be equal when you take the tangent
of this is equal to the tangent of
either the same thing or we could add
multiples of pi to it you could view it
as either way but now we just have to
solve this we can add five pi to both
sides of this equation we get sorry we
could add five theta to both sides of
this equation we're adding this to both
sides so you get six theta is equal to
PI over two minus n PI minus multiples
of pi all right sorry plus multiples of
pi this is a plus right over there
divide both sides by six I get theta is
equal to PI over 12 plus n times pi over
six or just to make the fraction adding
easier this is the same thing as PI over
12 plus two let me write it this way
plus two n PI over 12 this is the same
thing as n PI over six I just multiply
the numerator denominator by two and
this is the exact same thing you can
imagine a 1 coefficient out here this is
the same thing as 2 n plus 1 2 n plus 1
times pi over 12 so that's all of the
solutions that's all of the solutions
for this first
for this first equation right over there
now let's do the same thing for this
second equation and then we'll see where
they overlap in this range and we'll
take out anything that satisfies this
criteria right over here so the second
equation let me write it over here we
have sine of two theta let me write it
over here first cosine of 4 theta what
does cosine of 4 theta equal do cosine
of 4 theta using this same exact logic
is equal to sine of PI over 2 minus
theta and of course when we take a sine
or cosine or we take really a trig
identity or any trig function of any
angle you're going to get the same value
if you add multiples of 2 pi so let me
just add multiples of 2 pi here just so
that we can make sure that we get that
we get all the possible solutions so
this is what cosine of 4 theta is equal
to so let us let us let me be careful
cosine of 4 theta is not equal to PI
over 2 minus theta that would be cosine
of theta if it's closed sine of 4 theta
its PI over 2 minus 4 PI over 2 minus 4
theta plus multiples of 2 pi so plus 2
pi n because obviously you add multiples
of 2 pi you're going to go back to the
same angle so you go back to this
equation up here we get sine of 2 theta
sine of 2 theta is equal to cosine of 4
theta which is the same thing as this
over here which is equal to sine of PI
over 2 minus 4 theta plus plus 2 pi n
and so these evaluate to the same thing
let's set them equal to each other to
equal to each other 2 theta is equal to
PI over 2 minus 4 PI plus 2 pi n let's
add let's add 4 pi to both sides of this
equation we get 6 we get 6 theta 6 theta
is equal to PI over 2 so this is
cancelled out plus 2 pi n plus 2 pi n
let's divide both sides by 6 let's
divide both sides by 6 we get theta is
equal to pi
over 12 plus PI over 12 plus PI over 3 n
right 2 divided by 6 is PI n over 3 now
we can put it over a common denominator
just to simplify things so we have over
12 we have this pi PI n over 3 is the
same thing as plus 4 and PI over 12 or
we could write this as being this is
equal to 4 n plus 4 n plus 1 for n plus
1 times pi over 12 so now we just need
to see where there is overlap where
there is overlap between this solution
and that solution remember we just have
to count the number of solutions we
actually don't have to find the
solutions and actually if you're pretty
savvy you do things in your head just at
this point you can think about how many
how many of the how many of these you're
going to have between negative PI over 2
and PI over 2 if you remember that was
the range that we're working with
between negative PI over 2 and PI over 2
not including those two and then you
could figure out and actually every one
of these is also going to be one of
these because no matter what you set N
equal to if you said if you set N equal
to twice that you're going to have the
equivalent thing so any of these are
going to be any of these they're going
to anything that satisfies this equation
will also satisfy this equation right
here so really we can just count how
many are in this one but just to make it
clear I'm going to find all of them that
satisfy this equation and they're going
to see how many of those satisfy this
equation as well but the fast way to do
it just find the ones that satisfy this
one or just count the ones that satisfy
this one and you've done the problem so
let's just let's just count so let's
just start it n equals zero at if n if n
is equal to 0 and then I'm using this n
up here I won't even write that if n is
equal to 0 we just have PI over 12
if n if n is 1 we get 3 PI over 12 3 PI
over 12 if n is 2 we get 5 PI over 12
and we can't make any Quilly because if
n was equal to 3 this would be 7 PI over
12 which is greater than PI over 2
that's greater than 6
I over 12 so we can't have that we could
also go to negative n we could also have
negative n if n is negative 1 if n is
negative 1 then this becomes negative PI
over 12 negative PI over 12 if n is
negative 2 if n is negative 2 this
becomes negative 3 PI over 12 and if n
is negative 3 then this becomes negative
5 PI over 12 and once again we can't go
to n is equal to negative 4 because then
you get negative 7 PI over 12 which is
out of our range so this satisfies this
equation up here now which of these
satisfy with this over here so let's set
n equal to 0 we get PI over 12 if n is
equal to 1 if n is equal to 1 we get 5
PI over 12 we can't set n equal to 2
because then we'll get out of our range
we'll go above PI over 2 if n is equal
to negative 1 we get negative 3 PI over
12 if n is equal to negative 2 if n is
equal to negative 2 is negative 8 then
we get to negative 7 PI over 12 which is
smaller than negative PI over 2 so that
doesn't count so there are three
solutions or we if we look over here we
have three solutions we have one two
three solutions and none of them none of
them satisfy this none of them are
multiples of n PI over 5 so the answer
to our problem the answer to our problem
is 3 and you really could have just done
the second equation right over here and
realized that anything that's a solution
of this top equation would be a solution
to this bottom equation and you would
have just counted these solutions and
you would have been done